hell or high water was directed by David
McKenzie and stars Jeff Bridges Chris
Pine and Ben Foster and is the story of
two brothers who resort to robbing banks
to make some money for a very personal
reason now a lot of trailers and even
the plot synopsis on IMDB are telling
you why this reason is I'm not going to
because I went to this movie not knowing
the reason and it made it more
emotionally rich for me to discover that
as the film went along and that is
something that this entire film has an
emotional richness a lot of that is due
to incredibly good performances a very
tight script and finely tuned
deliberately slow paced editing that
paid off it was actually really
refreshing to see a movie take its time
with its characters and really sit back
and let the characters blossom let small
conversations happen Jeff Bridges in
this movie is like the Jeff Bridges
he's the Jeff Bridges you love and he
does kind of talk like this murder
Jujubee quuu Boudreau remember the grid
and he's so good at Mis movie I mean I
can't wait to get the blu-ray to put on
the subtitles but I still love Jeff
Bridges he's the dude I've always liked
Chris Pine I loved him in the Star Trek
movies I liked him quite a bit in
unstoppable and a smaller movie he did
called people like us but here he gives
a very emotionally subdued performance
that really impressed me and Ben Foster
I didn't even see Ben Foster he
disappeared into this character he
completely vanished fantastic acting and
in the past I haven't been the biggest
fan of Ben Foster but he blew me away in
this film it's all so gorgeously shot
beautiful cinematography a lot of
country music not a fan uh but it worked
in this movie and I can't really
downgrade the movies because I'm not a
fan of country music but it worked in
this film and it made it really feel
like Texas despite the fact that it's
actually not shot in Texas the bank
robbery scenes were very exciting but
there's nothing about it that felt
theatrical it felt very much so as if I
was watching something that could occur
it felt very realistic and I really like
that about this movie and I admired the
way they made this film it's actually
really
to pinpoint flaws with this film because
everything is done so well I suppose the
only issue that I really have with it is
that because it is slow-paced I'm not
seeing replay value being very high it's
amazing to look at the performances are
good everything about the movies great
there's also a fantastic side character
in this film Jeff Bridges partner and I
love the back-and-forth between these
guys they're the kind of guys that just
insult each other over and over again I
know a lot of guys like that I have a
lot of friends where we just rip each
other constantly and then we end with a
pat on the back and it's all good
because we know we're friends and that
was really cool to see between these
characters but there was also an amazing
undercurrent of depth in their
relationship that I thought was great
all in all hell or high water is a very
good western thriller that is a great
character study as well I'm gonna give
it an a-minus I'm sorry it took me so
long to review this movie I actually saw
it like two weeks ago and it's became a
thing where we officially moved into our
new house we moved all this furniture
and then we were having a renovation
done on our bathroom because it needed
repairs when we moved in and that
bathroom is right next to where I film
so my filming times were sort of
dictated by when they were not making a
ton of noise in the very next room
and when they were and so I try to get
it out as quick as possible but
gratefully I was able to talk about it
definitely check this one out guys it's
worth your time thank you so much as
always for watching and stay tuned this
Sunday because my series of ring reviews
is starting leading up to the newest
rings film you guys are the best once
again thank you for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
[Applause]
[Music]